so we're gonna get started this is this
is a complicated lecture to choreograph
but I'm gonna do my very very best
because I think it's there's some pretty
amazing stuff that we have to explain
that is carried out in nature and one of
those things is how do we replicate the
entire genome of organisms in one fell
swoop
almost perfectly sometimes there are
little errors and fast so we're gonna
refer to these numbers in a moment but
first of all I just want to get you back
in the picture of where we were at the
end of the last section the biochemistry
section and in the next few classes
we're going to address issues related to
the central dogma and the use of nucleic
acids for information storage and
information transfer and before I do
that I just want to highlight a couple
of things just in terms that you should
recall and recap from the biochemistry
section about nucleic acids so nucleic
acids form complimentary double strands
through base pairing and that base
pairing involves hydrogen bonding
between the nucleobases one purine to
one pyrimidine and the a T base pair is
worth two hydrogen bonds the GC base
pair is worth three hydrogen bonds and
those are actually pretty useful facts
to remember because they tell us about
the stability of double-stranded DNA
where it's easier to tease it apart and
other characteristics so it's kind of a
useful thing to keep in mind so the base
pairing between what's the purine
pyrimidine pair which sets the exact
register down the double-stranded DNA
that the backbone is the exact distance
apart because you always combine a small
pyrimidine with a much larger purine so
that's something you should feel
comfortable about the components are
organized in an anti parallel
orientation so one end is good runs 5
prime to 3 prime the other end runs 3
prime to 5 prime and I showed you last
time an image
that allows us to state quite clearly
that the anti-parallel orientation is
significantly more stable than the
parallel orientation because you can't
make all those great hydrogen bonds well
in the parallel organization apart from
everything else that becomes complicated
another important thing that you're
going to have to remember specially in
this lecture is that we add new
nucleotides to the 3 prime end of a
nucleic acid and so I'm just gonna put
this little guy in the corner here this
is the ribose sugar that would be where
the nuclear base is attached and it's a
deoxy sugar so there's not no
substituent at that carbon this is the
one position where the base is the 2
position where it's deoxy the 3 position
and these are all prime numbers remember
the sugars have prime numbers the bases
themselves have numbers without primes
to distinguish what we're talking about
so 3 4 5 and they're all prime and when
we grow the the single strand of DNA we
always add new basis to the 3 prime end
that's a an import enum burring system
so we have that piece of chalk so we
always grow from 5 prime to 3 Prime oops
and that will be important to you as we
go through the discussion today and then
finally a feature of DNA quite
double-stranded DNA quite unlike
proteins which sometimes you'll
thermally or with pH melt out and will
often have a problem reforming their
reliable structure because instead of
the structure refolding they aggregate
double-stranded DNA doesn't aggregate
because it's got all their negative
charges that would be quite repulsive
it would be very difficult for DNA
strands to aggregate as such because
there's too much of a concentration of
negative charges that would be repulsion
amongst the same type charges so DNA can
be peeled apart with heat and it will
really to its partner complementary
strand once you get to six seven eight
base pairs that is a nice interaction
between the strands and it forms
faithfully if we have a mistake in the
strands the stability of the double
strand would be a bit less and we can
measure that through physical
measurements that we carry out in the
lab so we can measure the denaturation
or the thermal melt temperature so we
call this interaction we call this
process rather after you separate
double-stranded DNA we call it reeling
or it's also designated as hybridization
to form a hybrid which is the composite
of the two structures those terms are
used fairly interchangeably all right so
the goals in the next four class is to
show you how the structures of the
nucleic acids really a purpose for the
sorts of processes that they undergo so
the replication of DNA the conversion of
a strand of DNA into complimentary
messenger RNA once the process of
protein synthesis needs to be initiated
that second step the first step is
called replication the second step when
you transcribe DNA into RNA is called
transcription and then finally when you
translate messenger RNA into proteins so
going to a completely new language we
call it a translation and that's the
basis of these of these lectures there's
a little bit of stuff in these lectures
about more complicated issues in the
mammalian cell where we have to process
the messenger RNA a bit before we can
have it leave the nucleus and I'll
explain the time at there when it comes
so this is the lineup for the four
lectures all right so what I already
talked to you how when you add I
mentioned it
here when you add sighted een
triphosphate gtp ATP TTP these are the
activated nucleobases
so they're the deoxy nucleotide
nucleoside triphosphates they are
nucleotides because they include
phosphate but when we describe them
we'll call them nucleoside triphosphates
if we're gonna mention the phosphate
part and I know that probably doesn't
make any sense at all right is everyone
okay with that if you're just
generically describing something with a
phosphate in it you call it a nucleotide
if you want to be a little bit more
specific you say nucleoside and then you
say how many phosphates alright and so
for the building blocks it's a
nucleoside triphosphate and believe me I
get that wrong all the time and I my
students correct me so I don't have a
problem if you if you're not perfect
with that nomenclature so these are the
building blocks for DNA for
polymerization and I just showed you how
you grow from the 5 prime end that
numbers not shown there but it's shown
over here and you add to the 3 prime end
and the convention remember when we
describe a strand of DNA because we make
it 5 prime to 3 prime we write it 5
prime to 3 prime just so that we're all
consistent and we know what we're
talking about now I want to talk about 2
experiments but enlist the use of
isotopes
because these were quite useful earlier
early on to describe some of the
characteristics of replications so some
of the details of replication and also
the fact the DNA was the genetic
material okay so isotopes are elements
that share the same number of protons
and electrons but they differ in the
number of neutrons okay so the common
isotopes of the elements that are in all
the covalent structures of the body are
hydrogen
carbon and what I'm putting is the
number next to it is the common isotope
so it's the number that number
designates the sum of the number of
neutrons and protons so carbon-12
phosphorus 31 I should have put nitrogen
here let's see wait I mean I'm gonna put
these in order because it makes more
sense
phosphorus 31 nitrogen 14 phosphorous 31
and sulfur
what's the sulphur isotope 32 so these
are the common isotopes that we that
comprise the majority of those elements
within the body but there are lots of
experiments done that have different
isotopes of these atoms that we can use
as tracers or markers kind of the same
thing but you'll see when I mentioned
the word tracer to me it brings up the
radioactive isotopes because we use very
little of them so when we talk about
these elements there are different
isotopes that we use commonly there's
the hydrogen that has an extra Neutron
that's also called deuterium and then
there's the hydrogen that is radioactive
it's metastable it will decay and emit a
radioactive particle so this one we
would call it the heavy isotope and this
one we would call the radioactive
isotope so we could trace certain
hydrogen's in biomolecules by either
making those hydrogen's the heavier ones
or making them the radioactive ones
carbon also has useful isotopes carbon
13 is the heavy isotope and carbon 14 is
the radioactive isotope so they're used
quite commonly and there
things get a little bit different for
nitrogen we use a heavy isotope of
nitrogen which is n15 just one extra
Neutron but while there is a radioactive
isotope of nitrogen it's too short of a
half-life to work with in the lab it's
not useful to us so we never talk about
it but we I will describe to you an
experiment with the heavy n15 when we
talk about the mechanism of replication
and then for phosphorus and sulfur the
most important ones are P 32 which is a
radioactive phosphorus and s 35 which is
a radioactive sulfur there's another
radioactive phosphorus that's P 33 has a
slightly longer half-life it's kind of
handy to work with if you have certain
experiments the half-life is very a lot
but the half-life of tritium c14 a long
that's why we do carbon dating the
half-life of P 32 a short you know less
day time frame and sulphur 35 is a
little bit longer but those are nuances
that you don't you don't need to worry
about now how are these isotopes useful
as tracers and markers to tell us about
biology and details of biology so what
I'm going to just show you here is a
particular experiment that's carried out
with what are known as baculovirus so
viruses infect eukaryotic cells
baculovirus --is infect bacteria so
there's a commonality there and when
baculovirus has infect bacteria just as
the parallel with eukaryotic cells they
deposit material into the bacteria so
they can replicate so they can hijack
the bacteria to make new viral new
baculovirus so what an early experiment
was done to ask what is the genetic
material that transfers the information
from the baculovirus to the to the
bacterial cell in order to make more
baculovirus right so they were able to
demonstrate in this Hershey and chase
experiment that you could raise
you labor you could label protein and
DNA with particular isotopes and find
out what part of the baculovirus was
important for transferring information
for the production of new baculovirus so
they wanted to label the capsid protein
so the proteinaceous material that's on
that's on the outside of this lunar
lander this is a baculovirus it's um
it's sort of amazing how it looks so I
wanted to label the protein but they
also wanted to label the contents of the
baculovirus the DNA with tracer Radio
isotopes so what would be the best
isotopes to use if you wanted to
differentiate between protein and
nucleic acid and what you want to think
about is what does protein have that
nucleic acids don't have and what the
nucleic acids have the proteins don't
have which which are the elements that
are important for differentiating yeah
over there yes phosphorus going do you
want to give a little bit more of a with
okay so the answer is we use phosphorus
to label nucleic acids because that
phosphodiester backbone it's rich in
phosphorus there are a few phosphates in
proteins but they're very transient
they're part of signaling but the boat
you know every nucleotide has phosphorus
in every building block and then in
proteins they have sulfur in them where
nucleic acids do not and the sulfur is
in two amino acids cysteine and
methionine so you can use those two
traces for the building blocks and the
way the experiment works is if you've
labeled the protein with sulfur you
infect a cell the virus replicates and
what you're gonna do is then centrifuge
the bacterial cells to see what's in the
cell and then you can alternatively
label the DNA and in this case I've
shown it as green but that would be the
other isotope let it infect the cell and
deposit its contents in the cell
centrifuge the cells out and you want to
know where the radioactivity is and the
radioactivity is strictly associated
with phosphorus-32 because the genetic
material that coded for the production
of new baculovirus is the thing that
stays associated with the bacterial cell
in contrast there's no radioactivity
associated when you label the cells with
s 35 all right nice experiment easy way
to do it quite a rather a nice way to do
it the other experiment I want to
describe to you very briefly because it
relies on centrifugation technology
that's very powerful and it's a method
that utilizes in 15 very very nicely
okay
so let me tell you about that experiment
there are things in the laboratory that
we use every day Ultra centrifuges and
regular centrifuges that spin at a very
fast speed where we can really
differentiate things by molecular mass
which relates to this the sedimentation
coefficients how fast does the particle
spin to the bottom of the tube when it's
under high centrifugal force the heavier
it is the faster it will spin so the
question that came up very early on it
looks like a nonsense question now
because it looks so obvious that we
replicate DNA the way we do but
originally wasn't absolutely certain
where the DNA was replicated through a
semi conservative mechanism where the
strands came apart and you made two
copies a copy of each strand to make two
identical daughter new double-stranded
DNA
alternatively could you have a mechanism
that was quite conservative you kept
your DNA and somehow you made a copy of
it a little harder for me to understand
so your two new strands one would look
like the original one but one would be
very different and they're all
dispersive where you're just copying
bits of the DNA and somehow reassembling
this gigantic jigsaw puzzle
the centrifugation experiment allowed
people to absolutely in clearly state
that the rep
occasion is via a semiconservative
process so let's walk through it and
what was done is that the nucleotides
within the DNA were all labeled with
heavy nitrogen so for every nucleic acid
let's say for example when there's an
adenine in the backbone there are five
nitrogen's so that would be five atomic
mass units heavier the nitrogen 14 in
that nuclear base and 15 nuclear base
five mass units heavier than n 14
nuclear base makes sense to everybody
all right so it's heavier by some amount
it's not a massive amount but it's
enough to differentiate in a
centrifugation experiment so the
bacteria will first grown up in heavy
nitrogen so all of the DNA sediments at
a certain rate and place and it's all
gone in 15 in it so it's as heavy as it
can said iment and then they let the
bacteria replicate in the presence of n
14 the lighter isotope of nitrogen and
what one would anticipate to happen is
whenever you replicate you peel apart
the two heavy strands and each one pairs
with a light strand okay so you now have
two copies two new identical copies of
DNA where half of the straf of this one
strand has n 15 one strand has N 14 so
it will sediment less quickly because it
is of a different density a lighter
density than the all N 15 so you would
get an intermediate weight band in this
centrifuge tube when you're sedimenting
if you peel those two strands apart
again you've got a heavy and a light if
you're growing in in 14 the light will
combine with another light that and
there are two of those and then the
heavy will combine with the light so
you'll get new sedimentation where you
still have a band that's the combination
of the light and heavy but then you
start having some material that is all
of the light so this would be this cycle
so two that are still light plus heavy
and then two that
Sibley light you keep on replicating and
your keep on diluting the heavy does
that experiment make sense it's kind of
a cool experiment you can hardly believe
it's feasible but the centrifugation
ability to differentiate with these
isotopes is really valuable
so I just want to put in a plug for the
use of isotopes obviously they're used
in nuclear physics we use a lot of the
radioactive isotopes for different
reasons but in biology they are
indispensable for some of these
experiments and even to this day you can
do things with isotopes you can't do
with a lot of that you can't do by other
experiments either the radioactive are
heavy there's a great deal of work done
nowadays in proteomics using mass
spectrometry and heavy isotopes where
you can really track where things go and
treat cancer cells differently from
healthy cells but actually track what's
happening by putting heavy isotopes in
one of the growing dishes of cells okay
so I like both of those experiments a
lot even though they're I would put them
in the category of oldies but goodies
all right now I've got some details over
here that we've got some explaining to
do
as we move forward and I just want to
first of all start with a couple of
details that I want to highlight on this
screen on this board rather first of all
bacteria and so prokaryotes such as
bacteria E coli and eukaryote such as
human cells have some differences in
their DNA so the size of the bacterial
genome is about five million base pairs
the size of the human genome is a foul
not quite a thousand times bigger but
really a good deal bigger the DNA in
bacteria is circular whereas the DNA in
eukaryotic cells is linear and it's
actually in the formula you see all
these little images where you see the
pairs of chromosomes are sort of stuck
together at the same
and that's linear DNA from one end to
the other in bacteria the DNA is
circular so it doesn't have an end so
they're different all right
so replicating circular DNA is a little
bit different from replicating linear
DNA all right now in both cases the DNA
has to be packaged up so it will fit in
the cell otherwise it's just too much of
a disordered thing in the case of
bacteria the circular DNA is wrapped up
and super coiled with what are known as
poly amines compounds that are very
positively charged to neutralize all
that negative charge in the DNA okay and
in man and other eukaryotes the
chromosomes are wrapped around very very
positively charged proteins known as
histones they're similar principles but
they're different entities okay so when
we start talking about replication of a
prokaryotic cell here's the typical
circular DNA so you can see the
double-stranded DNA and I've put a
little psy symbol here that I said that
I call the Ori
so that's origin of initiation so that
is the place where you start copying
your DNA and we're going to talk about
how to spot these places in genomes in a
moment and so the bacterial genome is
copied bi-directionally so you can go in
both directions copying you know in the
appropriate direction we'll talk about
that in a moment to make the entire
circular DNA and a perfect copy of the
DNA with bi-directional copying and
that's not bad for small genomes because
you've only got one origin of
replication you've got to get all the
way around the circular DNA all right
it's quite a bit smaller than the human
one but what you what do you do with
gigantic genomes such as the one that's
about you know
thousand times bigger than the bacterial
one how do you manage to still catalyze
the replication of the entire genome
quickly enough to make the copy of DNA
in some reasonable amount of time and
that is taken into taking also into
consideration that the speed of
bacterial replication is a thousand base
pairs per second pretty impressive
thousand of those bonds made every
second
whereas in eukaryotes it's somewhere
down from 50 base pairs per second
depending on conditions their numbers
these are not very explicit numbers
there's a little bit of variability so
how would you do it if you had to if you
had this massive chunk of gene and
you've got a copy it just really pretty
quickly in order to turnover replicate
an entire cell contents in 8 hours what
would you do how could you expect things
yeah yes so the answer here is starting
a lot of different places so there's a
lot of collaborative work going on all
along that large genome and so when the
the replication of the long linear
chromosomes that are in eukaryotic cells
you end up with just a lot of origins of
replication so you're basically starting
all over the place so you can get the
job done quickly enough for it to make
sense does that make sense to everybody
so starting a lot of places it's a
pretty easy thing all right now I
mentioned very briefly that when just
before you can copy DNA you have to
unpack it now we've got a lot of we
think a lot about packaging DNA less
about unpacking it but that's so I've
got these pictures sort of in a reverse
direction so it's only this form of DNA
stretched out that can be copied whereas
the DNA in your cells is bundled up very
tightly into chromosomes how are they
put together those chromosomes are made
up of chromatin which is a bunch of
balls which are histone protein
with DNA wrapped around them
chromatin that's compact chromatin oh
sorry sorry ice whoops we go back not to
go forwards so this is chromatin in a
compact form
this is chromatin now unraveled they
look more like beads on a string DNA
wrapped around each histone protein to
form those nucleus own structures and
then each nucleus own looks like this
it's got a protein in the middle and DNA
wrapped around it so in order to go
forward and replicate we have to
unpackage DNA there are lots of signals
to unpackage the DNA that we will talk
about later the nucleosomes look like
this so you can see you can trace the
DNA and the proteins bundled in the
middle and if we have time at the end I
will show you the video of the packaging
of DNA and the video of the replication
of DNA there about a minute and a half
each so it's not a whole bunch later on
we will talk about what happens when you
make that there is a determination that
a cell needs to replicate its genome a
bunch of things have to happen a signals
to do the unwrapping and one of those
things is actually to alter the charged
state of the histone proteins so you
neutralize the positive charges so the
DNA can unravel for it it makes sense
it's still just a plain old
electrostatic interaction so the
synthesis of DNA is what's known as
template driven polymerization
okay so template driven deer
polymerization you get a sense of
exactly what that means we know the two
strands are complementary and we're
gonna use one strand as the code to make
a new complementary strand so when we're
making DNA we have one strand there
that's the what's known as the template
strand I want to make a complimentary
copy of that strand
so what I'm gonna do what the DNA
polymerase is gonna do is systematically
add bases
sorry add nucleotides to the 3-prime Oh
H of the ribose and then you keep
growing but the base that gets put in is
the one that's complementary to the base
on the template strand so if it's I mean
on the template strand its adenine
puttin on the new strand and so on all
right and just to get these numbers
again the new strand is grown from 5
prime to 3 prime the old strand is red 3
prime to 5 prime so you're reading a
strand and you're reading it's 3 to 5
and you're making 5 to 3 that's how you
end up with complementary antiparallel
strands all right ok with that
everyone alright and when you form the
bond you go in with nucleoside
triphosphates you form a new phosphate
diaster were just one of those
phosphorous --is and you kick out
phosphate phosphate which we would call
pyrophosphate or diphosphate ok so here
you could just sort of see just check
what you think you know what you're
doing I'm gonna just say it's this is
really a pretty simple thing we're gonna
put in a T then we're gonna put in an A
then we're gonna put in a see because
our template is telling us to put in the
appropriate purine or pyrimidine that
forms a nice base pair with that so
there's a question here but that's I've
already given you the answer to it so it
should be very straightforward for you
to look at a template strand and decide
what would be on the complementary
strand and also decide on the
directionality of the complementary
strand all right now origins of
replication what do they look like we're
in that big weird where is the old where
do I start problem where do I start
what's the best place to start someone
not you not you anyone else want to
answer here where I've got this whole
genome I gotta get going I got to stop
me
copy of it where was the best place to
break into it to start making copies
yeah correct it's simple it's the
difference between two and three if you
go to the area where there's lots of G's
and sees every GC has three hydrogen
bonds if you go to a different area
where there happened to be a lot of A's
and T's in a row each pair is only worth
two hydrogen bonds you're gonna pick the
stretch that has the most days and T's
because it's the place where the base
pairing is weaker and it's a it's
actually a very simple concept so it
would be the 8e rich region is the place
where origins of replication and the
predominant okay so what we're gonna do
now and this is going to be tricky but
I'm gonna make this work is we're gonna
talk about replicating an entire chunk
of gene and what I've done here is I put
the pieces that we're gonna discuss over
here
that's my menu and we're gonna work
through what we need to copy a large
chunk of DNA all right everybody with me
so I redrew this this morning I promised
myself I'm gonna be super tidy on this
blackboard which is a far stretch from
me
so replication we know where replication
starts a tea rich region we could pick
those out in the genome we know that
we've got to unwind the DNA to make a
copy of it so we must have had to unwrap
the DNA beforehand these are all known
things so let's now take a look at
double-stranded DNA and try and figure
out how we use all the components such
I'm going to bring this board down
because I don't see it as well up there
how do we make use of all these
components that are part of the menu
that we need to make the new strand of
DNA so we have double stranded DNA
and there are base pairs across so
that's typical double-stranded DNA
that's what we're starting from
unwrapped I haven't made it helical
because my Gila C's will get messy and
so we need to start so what the first
thing that will happen is that the the
important enzymes like the helicase will
scan to find an origin of replication so
somewhere for the for the process to
start cuz that's where they're gonna
break in so David one of your TAS works
for ste in Steve Bell's lab and they
study the mammalian origin of
replication complex which is this much
more complicated situation than what I'm
going to describe to you today but they
do fabulous single molecule work to
assemble to show how those pieces are
assembled but I'll tell you the truth as
dorky as I am the thing that I find the
most cruel about the origin of
replication complex is that the the
expelled orc and if any of you are Lord
of the Rings fans who can't be excited
by a complex called the or complex
alright so there's going to be the the
screening of the genome for an Ori and I
want you to remember that what is up
here is the rest of the chromosome it's
not just a fuzzy end it's something
that's got a lot of stuff there that
still be spared so the first thing that
happens is that helicase needs to start
unzippering the two of the
double-stranded DNA so you get to a new
intermediate we're gonna draw like this
and the helicase is going to intercept
to basically start separating those two
strands of DNA in order to do the
replication don't forget that these are
still base paired and these now are
single strands so I'm gonna need
something from that menu I'm gonna need
it quickly what do you think's the next
thing we're really gonna need in order
to be able to move forward in our job
what do we need from over here we're
we're already using the double-stranded
DNA it's not gonna be too difficult to
figure out that NT piece we're already
using the unzip arrays the helicase what
are we gonna need yeah primase ah
primase shortly but we've really got to
do something to stabilize our unzip and
stuff anyone else so those two single
strands are right near each other and
they're complementary what's gonna stop
them going straight back together again
and not allowing replication so there
are proteins that basically sit on the
single-stranded parts of DNA that are
known a single strand binding proteins
that stabilize this transiently made
complex long enough for it to be copied
all right so we've so far we've used the
helicase we've used the single strand
binding proteins and i'm gonna draw them
there all right still remembering that I
have an entire chromosome up here now
the heavy lifting has to start fairly
soon so we need the enzyme that's going
to start making a copy of one of those
single strands
that's going to be a DNA polymerase
which is right here but DNA polymerase
is kind of a finicky enzyme because it
doesn't like to just start cold on the
genome on the single strand and start
making a copy DNA polymerase needs a
primer of some kind all right so I'm
gonna just put that as a note up here
DNA polymerase needs what's called a
primer and what is a primer a primer is
a sequence I think I've got something up
here a primer is a sequence that's
complementary to a little bit of DNA so
that when DNA polymerase comes along
it's actually grabbing a double strand
and then filling up the rest of the
single strand so this would be a typical
depiction of a prime a here's a strand
we want to copy but the blue one is a
primer strand giving you something
double-stranded to hold on to and then
in this situation DNA polymerase would
be happy to fill in the rest of the
sequence so for the purpose of this
discussion to start we're just going to
provide a primer that is complementary
to the DNA just to give us a go we have
an alternative in the cell where is to
actually use a primase and RNA building
blocks to build a primer but let's keep
things simple for a minute and get on
with a lot of the major work and then
we'll come back to that in a second so
this part is a primer and that primer if
this is the 3 prime end that's five
prime three prime so the primer is
complementary to the DNA in that
direction is anti parallel and then DNA
polymerase can go along and fill in the
Strand and I'm gonna draw it dashed and
it's gonna keep on growing and what I
want you to notice his DNA polymerase
grows from five prime
two three pride that is a cardinal rule
the directionality that we grow the new
DNA in so basically looking at this
picture it's going in this direction
alright because the 3-prime o H is free
and you're building onto it so you use a
primer first and then you use DNA
polymerase plus deoxy nucleoside try
phosphates
so all those 80 CG building blocks so
we've been using these we've used the
single stranded binding proteins we've
used a primer but there are an
alternative I'll get to that in just a
second but we now have a complex where
I'm gonna briefly divert you to tell you
about in the cell what else you could
use as a primer and then we're gonna
have to deal with copying this other
strand
but this first strand that is made is
called the leading strand it's the one
that's easy I peel apart the DNA I have
a primer there and I can just build goes
really smoothly I'm building in the
right direction if you look over on the
other side of the fence you've got a
problem because I can't build on this
side from here right why not yeah I'd be
doing it the wrong direction I would be
the total mess frankly there would be a
crisis in the cell so we're gonna have
to deal with that so let me just get you
out of the primer just deal with this
primer issue in the cell it's not like
we can micro inject all these little
primers to get our DNA synthesized so
RNA polymerase believe it or not
doesn't need a primer so you can build
little bits of primer with RNA you don't
build very much just build short
segments and then once you've got sort
of enough there DNA polymerase can start
polymerizing so you you use RNA
polymerize a nucleotide nucleoside
triphosphates not the deoxy ones so
later on we've got this piece here that
might be made of RNA which is why coming
over here to my menu do I have it yes we
need an RNA RNA primase and we need RNAs
to chop them out so that DNA polymerase
can come back because now there is
double-stranded material and fill in the
gap and then we need one more enzyme to
stitch together the gaps and that's the
ligase the logic of this stuff is great
I think it's just really amazing because
all these moving parts have evolved to
make all these functions fall into place
now we need to talk about this pesky
other strand okay so we have a problem
here because we've got the wrong
directionality so what happens in nature
is a prime as soon as there's enough of
a stretch a primer is put in place
growing the DNA in the right direction
that's from where the origin of
replication zipping so we put in another
primer and then DNA polymerase that's a
white one can build its complementary
strand building in the appropriate
direction to be consistent so you
basically fill in a chunk and then you
have to wait awhile til more is on
zippered put in another primer and then
grow the DNA so in that other piece
you're making little segments of DNA
intervened by RNA primers later on those
small primers are going to be chewed up
by RNAs DNA polymerase is gonna fill
them in and ligase is going to join them
that makes sense it's a lot to grasp and
this other side is called what's known
as the lagging strand and there are
pieces of short DNA that have
transiently made that have had their own
name you can remember it or not I just
feel I'm not being complete if I don't
describe mention their name they're
called Okazaki fragments after the guy
who discovered them and they're longer
in bacteria than in humans so Okazaki
fragments are the transient short
stretches that are made of DNA that are
made in the lagging strand and then they
get zipped together so that's sort of
the story for replicating the DNA I mean
make sure I've described everything to
you leading strand lagging strand
oh I believe I almost got this all right
now we got a problem so we've come all
this way we've used all the pieces we
haven't used one of the pieces all right
so we're in a small bit of trouble
because what's gonna happen when you're
for example we're trying to peel apart
your DNA what's what trouble are you
gonna run into who wants to come up here
and get involved in my demo and you've
got to be aware that you're gonna be on
screen you and you up there you got your
hand up first okay I need someone who's
going to hold on to this as if their
life depends on it you can't let the
yellow one slip out so you and the rest
of the chromosome so make sure that
you're really hold and you don't let
things come apart now you are helicase
okay okay so come on start HeLa casing
and so I can get and really pull as hard
as you can he's gonna hold it no I don't
want you to unwind it because we're in
the middle of a chromosome so you you've
literally got to do what helicase does
yeah keep on pulling come on you can do
it
can you go much further I mean a your
arms lightly low but it's almost
impossible right we get to a stage where
we need hell
the help we have coming just from
topoisomerase topoisomerase does
something so let's walk just one step
this way so those yeah topoisomerase
comes along and it cuts the DNA it holds
the pieces in its hands if you will
let's the supercoiling relax and then it
joins them back again so topoisomerase
thank you very much guys that's it
chromosome helicase thank you we really
have some tightly wound DNA here so
topoisomerase is the
get-out-of-jail-free card
because it allows you to deal with all
of this tension you got in place that
you cannot unravel so you need someone
who's literally gonna cut holes
let the thing relax rejoin it and there
also there are some topoisomerases
called DNA gyrase is but the really cool
thing about topoisomerase is that it's a
wonderful drug target in both mammalian
and bacterial cells because they're
quite different in the two types of
organisms so in bacteria the antibiotic
ciprofloxacin is a topoisomerase
inhibitor that actually stops your
bacteria dividing because if topo
doesn't work you can't go on and in
human biology and cancer biology there
are also topoisomerases there's one
called contra Thiessen that does the
same thing in the eukaryotic
topoisomerase to stop cancer cells
dividing rapidly so that those cannot be
cannot go on and make larger tumors so I
want to show you something and I am
actually certain that I have time come
on now I'm gonna show you in this
animation we'll see the remarkable way
our DNA is tightly packed up so that six
feet of this long molecule fits into the
microscopic nucleus of every cell
the process starts when DNA is wrapped
around special protein molecules called
histones the combined loop of DNA and
protein is called a nucleosome
next the nucleosomes are packaged into a
thread the end result is a fiber known
as chromatin
[Music]
this fiber is then looped and coiled yet
again
[Music]
leading finally to the familiar shapes
known as chromosomes which can be seen
in the nucleus of dividing cells I'm
going to take you forward using computer
animation based on molecular research we
are now able to see how DNA is actually
copied in living cells you are looking
at an assembly line of amazing miniature
biochemical machines that are pulling
apart the DNA double helix and cranking
out a copy of each strand the DNA to be
copied enters the production line from
bottom-left the whirling blue molecular
machine is called helicase it spins the
DNA as fast as a jet engine as it
unwinds the double helix into two
strands
[Music]
one strand is copied continuously and
can be seen spooling off to the run
things are not so simple for the other
strand because it must be copied
backwards it is drawn out repeatedly in
loops and copied one section at a time
the end result is two new DNA molecules
[Music]
all right okay that's what you saw today
replication a lot of the mechanics a lot
of the moving parts there's this tricky
stuff with primers you'll get used to
that
but this is really the quintessential
set of pieces to replicate DNA it is an
amazing process
look at the speed thousand base pairs a
second can you even believe it
a chromis entire cyclic circular
chromosome copied in 20 minutes so these
are really things to think about because
they're so impressive that it's a
delight to actually be able to teach
them to you okay I'm done for today
you